what like do you remember hearing about
nipy passing away and how he passed away
when you were incarcerated yeah I do I
remember that day nipy was my favorite
rapper I wish I could be more like I'm
nothing like nipy his mind was just sick
like I said I want to be the Mexican y
but like nipy was just his mentality and
the thing that he did the way he made
all money in grinding all my life all
that just is legendary best rapper top
three one of mine top three rappers all
time nipy
Eminem probably the game probably not
yeah dog man Spas homies on the gang huh
those fools are hard you know they are
hopefully I'm your favorite rapper top I
had name top three all time Eminem nipy
Hustle the
game that's a good three twox hard too
but n those
guys I'm going with the game
nipy so if you the third one NY
Gunplay